die wissenschaft und die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse der
wissenschaftler sind ja selten so
gefragt gewesen wie in den letzten
wochen und monaten denn was wir über das
corona virus wissen dass wissen wir halt
eben aus der forschung aber wir wünschen
uns halt klare erkenntnisse eine
schnelle ergebnisse am besten damit
hätte wissen können wie wir uns am
besten zu verhalten haben aber wir
lernen halt jetzt auf die harte tour
wissenschaft braucht doch relativ viel
zeit da muss geforscht werden
da gibt es eine studie und diese eine
studie ist eben nicht die wahrheit
sondern eben nur eine studie die
wissenschaftler untereinander das
stellen wir jetzt auch fest sind sich
dann auch selten sofort einig sondern da
wird gestritten und gerungen
und diese diskussion hat den forschern
die hat die bild zeitung diese woche zum
thema gemacht und das hat für viel
verwirrung und auch ärger gesorgt unter
anderem wegen der frage wie die bild
-zeitung das ganze gemacht hat wir
wollen uns heute mal ansehen worum es da
eigentlich geht und wer da vielleicht
auch recht hat wenn wir das überhaupt
sagen können und jetzt schon feststellen
können und was wir aus der ganzen
geschichte vielleicht lernen können und
dafür ist der biologe martin stürmer bei
uns der auch ein labor in frankfurt
leitet hat der stürmer genannt ich grüße
sie hätten sie immer damit gerechnet
dass wissenschaftliche
zwischenergebnisse eines tages in der
boulevardpresse auf der seite 1
diskutiert werden ja ist die frage ob
das eine ehre ist nein ich hab damit
ehrlich gesagt nicht gerechnet weil
wissenschaft zu diskutieren ist
natürlich immer gut und richtig
und das kann man natürlich auch in der
öffentlichkeit in einer bestimmten form
tun
aber in dieser form wie es da
letztendlich in den tagen jetzt passiert
ist ist es eigentlich ist erstens sehr
ungewohnt und zweitens auch nicht die
art wie man wissenschaft diskutieren
sollte für alle die es nicht genau
wissen was da eigentlich passiert ist
weil sie es nicht verfolgt haben hat
anna maria schuck nochmal schnellen
überblick für uns gemacht
drosten studie über ansteckende kinder
grob falsch titelte die bild zeitung
anfang der woche heftige kritik am
virologen christian drosten und seiner
forschung seine corona studie sei
komplett daneben
und rosten reagierte im vorfeld vertritt
warf der bild tendenziöse
berichterstattung vor und verweigerte
eine stellungnahme auch weil die bild
ihm nur eine stunde zeit geben wollte
auf die kritik zu reagieren
ich kann die kritik von torsten durchaus
nachvollziehen das ist natürlich im bowl
war so dass extrem zugespitzt wird das
auch oft dann mit einer haltung mit
einer meinung argumentiert wird und das
wird eigentlich der wissenschaftlichen
diskussion dem streit den man in der
wissenschaft auch zur produktivität
braucht nicht gerecht und darum geht's
in dieser corona studie kommt rosten zu
dem vorläufigen vorsichtigen ergebnis
kinder könnten ebenso infektiös sein wie
erwachsene
ein ergebnis das für politiker in der
debatte um kita öffnungen interessant
sein dürfte wenn es sich denn bestätigt
denn an der studie wird noch gearbeitet
wenn wir über derartige studien
berichten dann sind wir doppelt
vorsichtig wir holen uns natürlich dann
auch stimmen von anderen fachleuten dann
hinzu und können dabei in diesen stand
der der publikation noch nicht sagen
eine studie ist falsch oder richtig
dafür fehlt uns selbst das
wissenschaftsjournalisten an die
kompetenz die bild zeitung aber zweifelt
und zitiert wissenschaftler die sich
kritisch äußern
zitate aus dem zusammenhang gerissen so
der vorwurf von boston und auch die
zitierten forscher selbst haben sich
mittlerweile öffentlich von der
bildberichterstattung distanziert bild
-chef reichelt hält dagegen sieht seine
zeitung als letzte instanz der
kritischen fragen und bild zu sagen dass
er sich für grob falsch
wir reden doch das in allen medien
kontrovers diskutiert wird natürlich
auch personalisierte kontrovers
diskutiert wird über die virologin und
virologen über politikerinnen und
politiker und über den umgang eben mit
den lockerungen oder nicht nur nicht
lockerungen beispielsweise in der korona
krise
und auch fach kritik an einer vorab
applikation ist in der wissenschaft
nichts ungewöhnliches ist sogar
erwünscht um eine studie weiter
entwickeln zu können kritisieren
diskutieren und überarbeiten so
funktioniert fortschritt und übrigens
auch journalismus ja da gibt es aber
relativ viel diskussionen gerade um
diese vor veröffentlichung und um die
frage wie die bild -zeitung damit
umgegangen ist darüber diskutieren wir
heute mit martin stürmer virologe und
leiter eines labors frankfurt eure
fragen bitte in die kommentare ich habe
schon sehr viel gelesen da hat sich
schon einiges zusammen aufgestaut das
gucke ich mir gleich mal an aber
vielleicht grundsätzlich müssen wenn man
diese frage mit der vorveröffentlichung
klären wir haben ja schon im beitrag
gelernt das machen man dann wird
diskutiert wird aber das finde ich ja
normalerweise nicht so in der
öffentlichkeit statt oder das ist
korrekt also wenn wir studien
publizieren möchten also veröffentlichen
möchten
dann machen wir das auf dem weg dass man
das dann einfach journal schickt diese
arbeit amon wenn dort jemand sagt der
verantwortliche sagt ja das ist für
unser journal gute arbeit dann wird das
ein externer gutachter geschickt die
sich das dann kritisch durchlesen und
dann wird dieses ganze hinterfragt und
im prinzip in einem internen diskurs
werden die punkte ausgetauscht und
jedenfalls auch überarbeitet das bekommt
die öffentlichkeit in der regel
eigentlich gar nicht mit die zweite art
wie man wissenschaftliche daten
präsentiert ist auf so genannten
fachkongressen auch da muss man vorher
erstmal seine arbeit einreichen die wird
auch dort geprüft ob sie überhaupt für
den kongress in der lage oder überhaupt
wert ich genug ist für diesen kongress
und dann stellt man sich eben auch wenn
man seine daten präsentiert hat der
öffentlichen diskussion im
wissenschaftlichen kreisen aber ist es
dann nicht auch vielleicht ist ein guter
schritt dass man sagt okay wir öffnen
das ganze und wir können das man als
öffentlichkeit tatsächlich zu sehen wie
so eine wissenschaftliche erkenntnis zu
tage kommt und sich da auch
wissenschaftler einigen
natürlich ist das prinzipiell nicht
verkehrt damit man einfach ein gefühl
dafür bekommt die wissenschaft wirklich
funktioniert das
im prinzip wenn man eine studie
abgeschlossen hat das nicht das ende der
fahnenstange ist und die absolute
weisheit verkündet sondern dass das auch
ein prozess in dem man seine daten neu
diskutiert gegebenenfalls auch noch mal
überarbeitet und das ist völlig normal
das ist jetzt immer wieder zu diesen vor
veröffentlichung kommt ohne diesen sagen
wir mal vorab erfolgten prüfungs schritt
geht natürlich auch daran dass relativ
schnell auch die daten anderen kollegen
zur verfügung gestellt werden sollen
damit man eben in breiten kreisen
diskutieren kann weil wir eine akute
situation haben mit einem virus dass wir
fünf monate kennen und dass natürlich
jeder wissens zu gewinn den wir bekommen
können auch zeitnah notwendig und
entsprechend auch in der breiten
wissenschaftlichen diskussion
und wenn die öffentlichkeit daran
teilhaben möchte und soll ist uns das
natürlich recht aber es muss auf einem
vernünftigen niveau stattfinden und das
ist denn ein vernünftiges niveau ich
nehme hier den gastbeitrag von herrn
kekulé das ist er auch ein arzt und
biochemiker leiter des lehrstuhls oder
inhaber des lehrstuhls unter anderem für
die biologie an der luther universität
halle
der hat heute im tagesspiegel gesagt
diese studie sollte zurückgezogen werden
und dann hat herr drosten das können wir
kurz uns angucken auf twitter reagiert
und hat gesagt piccoli macht stimmung
sind darstellung ist tendenziös erkennen
unsere daten nicht zitiert falsch
piccoli selbst könnte man sich
kritisieren dazu müsste er erst mal
etwas publizieren also eine breitseite
in richtung das ja im grunde doch auch
kollegen ist das jetzt das niveau das
sie sich wünschen
nein natürlich nicht ich denke ich kenne
christian drosten auch nicht ich denke
mal erst mal blickt ein bisschen auch
dünnhäutig und hätte vielleicht unter
anderen umständen jetzt nicht in der
form reagiert aber das kann ich aus der
ferne nicht nicht wirklich beurteilen
natürlich ist es so dass wenn ein
kollege was zu kritisieren hat dann muss
man das nicht unbedingt in einem
gastbeitrag in der zeitung machen
da kann man eine e mail an den kollegen
schickt man sagen hier passt mal auf ich
habe mir das ganze mal durchgeschaut und
finde
das ganze ist nicht in ordnung und die
form haben wir natürlich über
öffentlichkeit diskussion geredet wenn
ich in der öffentlichkeit so diskutiere
dann stelle ich auch nicht so herrsche
forderungen und sage der kollege muss
das komplett zurückziehen weil die
studie komplett auch falsch ist weil das
ist definitiv nicht der fall wir reden
gerade in diesem kontext hier über eine
über die statistik also über das modul
in einer arbeit was einem ein gefühl
dafür gibt oder oder eine aussage dafür
gibt ist diese ergebnisse die ich habe
ist das ein zufallsprodukt oder ist es
tatsächlich
meine aussage mit mit vernünftigen
parametern so woide dass sich das
aussagen kann und der kern der studie
bleibt natürlich bestehen die ergebnisse
haben sich nicht geändert
und deswegen ist das natürlich auch eine
form auch von mpq lädt die die nicht
hätte sein müssen wir gucken jetzt mal
die kommentare da hat sie schon sehr
viel aufgestaut zb schreibt pocher auf
facebook können wir auf mein dokument
hier schalten wir die kollegen
netterweise schon was wissen
zusammengetragen haben haste 10
virologen hast du zehn meinungen da
gönnt der andere dem einen keinen
millimeter aufmerksamkeit sie scheinen
zu genießen aber auch das ziel führend
ist das lasse ich jetzt mal einfach so
als meinungsäußerung so stehen dann
kommt ein interessanter anrufe auf
youtube von me myself and i liebes zdf
wissenschaft das war seit jeher rede und
gegenrede dieses dialektische prinzip
lässt sich zurückverfolgen bis zu platon
die tatsache dass wissenschaft nur noch
die rede eines star virologen ist ist
relativ neu wir kehren damit also nur zu
einem seite antike praktizierten prinzip
zurück und das ist gut so
ja da schließen ist ein bisschen den
vorwurf auch gegen die medien dass man
nur noch sich auf christian drosten
gestürzt hat und er immer zu wort
gekommen ist sehen sie das auch so
hätten wir oder hätten medien noch mehr
und andere virologen tatsächlich auch
fragen sollen oder müssen also um es bei
dieser zehn virologen zehn meinungen
noch mal ein bisschen einzufangen ich
denke dass wir im grundsatz eigentlich
gar nicht so weit auseinander liegen
wenn sie sich so insgesamt die meinung
der biologen angeguckt haben zu zu
lockerungen oder zu den los
locker und maßnahmen dabei wollte ich
immer relativ in einer richtung in den
oasen sicherlich auch unterschiedlich
was den hype anfänglichen hype um
christian drosten angeht war muss 1
feststellen christian drosten ist seit
jahren oder eigentlich seit jahrzehnten
in der korona virusforschung an welt
führender virologe und wir können dass
in deutschland wirklich schätzen dass er
hier in deutschland weiterhin seine
arbeit tätigt und dementsprechend kann
ich absolut nachvollziehen dass sich die
politik mit ihm auseinandergesetzt hat
um eben nicht aus zehn meinungen sich
ein urteil zu bilden sondern aus dem
fachmann der auch das nationale
referenzlabor bc konsiliarlabor für
coronaviren leitet insofern finde ich
das gerechtfertigt dass letztendlich
eher als meinungsbildner für die politik
in erster linie auch gefragt worden ist
jetzt schreibt ihr heike otto auf
facebook wir sollten dankbar sein dass
wir jetzt mal live erleben wie
wissenschaft funktioniert auch der regen
meinungsaustausch gehört dazu jeder
wissenschaftler steht auf dem fundament
der wissenschaft und werde auf die
spaltung herbeiredet sind vorwiegend die
medien
das kann man ja zu stehen lassen aber
tatsächlich ist die frage ob man sich
dann auch in den medien selber nochmal
äußern muss und hier gibt es aber eine
ganz interessante anmerkung von enrico
kahl auf twitter der schreibt es gab und
wird es immer geben
das ist auch heftige dispute gibt wofür
es habe ich das sorry mal hier kurz weg
gemacht der druck ist enorm aber kann
die wissenschaft es überhaupt liefern
die meisten studien haben jedoch alle
das problem zu kleiner probandengruppen
und deren hochrechnung ist
fehleranfällig das ist ja auch so ein
bisschen die kritik jetzt an dieser
studie von professor posten und seinem
team oder das ist korrekt
wir haben das problem das wir gerade bei
den kleinen kindern über die wir ja
hauptsächlich kann diskutieren in allen
tests umgebungen über egal welches labor
sie gucken sind die kleinkinder
unterrepräsentiert im vergleich zur
normalbevölkerung wir haben relativ
kleine fallzahlen und da krankt
natürlich alles an studien dran
nichtsdestotrotz sind dass eben die
daten die wir zur verfügung haben und
die müssen wir es halt auch vernünftig
anschauen und die müssen wir natürlich
auch kritisch diskutieren und
natürlich muss auch erlaubt sein eine
statistik zu hinterfragen
aber wie gesagt die statistik die man
über eine studie darüber laufen lässt
ändert erst mal nichts an den rohdaten
die man hat und die rohdaten sind da und
die kann man nicht verändern magenkrebs
von nicolae der hat gesagt die rohdaten
nicht so erhoben worden dass man die
wirklich vergleichen kann weil die
probanden hatten verschiedene
krankheitsverläufe da ist verschieden
vielleicht abgeschrieben wurden
von daher gab es ja schon der kritik
dass diese rohdaten vielleicht gar nicht
richtig sind sehr gut aber das haben sie
natürlich in allen studien die sie
gemacht weil es wird nie in keiner
keinem kollektiv kann ich wirklich zu
100 prozent sicher sein dass immer die
gleiche person den abstrichen immer der
gleichen stelle mit immer der gleichen
intensität gemacht hat also das ist ein
argument das kann ich so in der form
nicht akzeptieren weil sonst können wir
gar keine daten verwenden
aus diesen ganzen erhebungen sicherlich
was richtig ist ist über die den
krankheitsverlauf das im prinzip aus
unterschiedlichen stadien die die proben
stammen
das hat herr osten aber auch selber in
einem kommentar fest gestellt und auch
kommentiert und dazu stellung bezogen
hat gesagt dass sie das in einem zweiten
schritt entsprechend auch nach arbeiten
werden und das ist im prinzip das was
auch sein muss in der diskussion man hat
ein ergebnis publiziert also
veröffentlicht man sieht es nicht zurück
sondern man stellt ist der diskussion
und wenn der kritik kommt denn
überarbeitet mann und entwickelt das
ganze projekt weiter
das ist der richtige weg und so will es
ja letztendlich auch gemacht wenn wir
nochmal zu diesen vorveröffentlichungen
kommen zu dieser praxis die ja gerade
irgendwie doch so ein bisschen normal
wird da gab es ja schon bei der
heinsberg studie von professor hendrik
strikt ärger der hat ja eine richtige
pressekonferenz gemacht deswegen und hat
dann hinterher auch viel kassieren
müssen öffentlich jetzt hat professor
thorsten seine vor veröffentlichung in
seinem podcast angekündigt ist das
vielleicht so generell nicht die beste
idee das haus zu posaunen dass man eine
erste ergebnisse hat und dann erstmal zu
warten bis die arbeitskollegen drauf
geguckt haben das würde ich als
journalist mit meinen artikeln zum
beispiel auch so machen ich glaube wir
haben ein bisschen einfach dieses
zeitproblemen es sind natürlich im
augenblick zeiten in denen wir uns oder
in denen erwartet wird dass wir relativ
schnell wichtige ergebnisse und wichtige
fragestellungen auch beantworten und der
wolf es sein dass man wenn man diesen
druck nachgibt das dann manchmal
vielleicht auch die qualität auf der
strecke bleibt und ich denke das ist
tatsächlich nicht optimal ist daten im
form an der pressekonferenz zu
präsentieren soll ich hätte mir auch für
die heinsberg studie gewünscht dass das
was im nachgang natürlich auch gemacht
worden ist im prinzip auch was herr
christian drosten gemacht hat dass beide
einfach ihre ihre forschungsergebnisse
in form dieser dieser veröffentlichung
auf die plattformen stellen so dass man
wenn man schon anfängt zu diskutieren
gleich eine an festes papier hat und
einen verlauf mit welchen patienten hat
man gearbeitet mit welchen tests hat man
gearbeitet mit werkstatt in der
heinsberg studie in der sie das auch
nicht aber in der pressekonferenz der
heinsberg studie sind all diese
informationen gar nicht verfügbar
gewesen für für uns kollegen sondern da
ist im prinzip ein ein ergebnis in einer
form präsentiert worden
die halt eben unvollständig war und auf
deren basis man nicht intern auch nicht
hätte diskutieren können und insofern
klar ich möchte dass meine daten
diskutiert werden dann muss ich dafür
auch ein bisschen die werbetrommel
rühren
aber natürlich kann man sich überlegen
ob man das nicht insgesamt interne macht
und später die daten in einer nahezu
fertigen und möglicherweise nicht mehr
ganz so fehlerhaften form präsentiert
aber dann verliert man auch relativ viel
zeit weil der klassische prozess dieses
reviews in den literatur
fachzeitschriften
da kann sich auch mal über monate
hinziehen und das ist etwas was wir uns
im augenblick wahrscheinlich nicht
leisten können und sollten da kommt
jetzt doch vielleicht ein kommentar von
simon kremer auf youtube dazu den nicht
ganz passend finde er meint hier steht
nicht zur diskussion hin und wird nichts
gespalten das ganze ist eine medien
kampagne der bild die keine ahnung hat
wie wissenschaft funktioniert und dem
normalen wissenschafts diskurs ein
skandal sehen will
den es nicht gibt die studie war
vorläufig da können fehler drin sein
daher sollen kollegen die man unter die
lupe nehmen und kritisieren ganz normal
nur weil das nun politisch angeschaut
wird gelten plötzlich ganz andere
maßstäbe
ist das vielleicht tatsächlich der kern
des problems dass politik da jetzt mit
rein mischt und auch natürlich
ergebnisse haben möchte um irgendeine
handlungssicherheit zu haben ich habe
auch schon wissenschaftler gehört die
jetzt angst haben dass sie später die
prügelknaben werden dass man gesagt dass
die politiker dann sagen die
wissenschaftler haben es gesagt also
tatsächlich ist eine schwierige
gemengelage von wissenschaftlicher
erkenntnis findung und politik gerade
vorhanden also wissenschaft sollte
sollte unabhängig von politik sein ganz
klar also die ergebnisse sollten nicht
in irgendeiner weise politisch motiviert
wirken oder oder in irgendeiner form
auch politisch motiviert sein das muss
man natürlich versuchen zu vermeiden
und ich glaube das ist das problem das
man im prinzip die studie von christian
drosten versucht in einen politischen
kontext zu zwingen dass man eben
unterstellt er hätte die aussagen so
geformt dass es der politik halt gerade
in den kram passt aber da bin ich mir zu
100 prozent sicher
so wie christian drosten kenne dass das
nicht der fall ist und vollkommen
richtig politik und wissenschaft sollte
definitiv getrennt sein und muss
getrennt sein
wir machen erstmal hier einen punkt
herrscht immer was diese ganze gemenge
lage um die studie angeht und gucken uns
mal was anderes an den politik ist ein
deutschland das thema ist unter druck
viele branchen stehen mit dem rücken zur
wand da müssen sehr große
milliarden-hilfen aktiviert werden damit
die wirtschaft nicht komplett
zusammenbricht viele maßnahmen wurden
auch unter dem öffentlichen druck her
schon gelockert
jedes bundesland machte aber so ein
bisschen was ist möchte und das führt
auch zu verwirrung und die folgen davon
können wir noch gar nicht absehen und
anika braun hat hat sich dass wir uns
mal angeguckt
abstand halten kontakte beschränken das
gilt bundesweit bis zum 29 juni der rest
ist ländersache und der vergleich bayern
brandenburg zeigt zu welch
uneinheitlichen regelungen das führt
hotels dürfen in brandenburg heute
wieder öffnen in bayern erst am 30
auch freibäder waren in brandenburg
heute schon wieder offen erst am 8 juni
in bayern brandenburg erlaubt private
feiern mit bis zu 50 gästen und ab dem
15 juni erlaubt bayern theatern und
kinos den betrieb leer in ostfriesland
wie brüchig die erfolge im kampf gegen
die pandemie sind hat sich dort
vergangene woche gezeigt an einem abend
haben sich in diesem restaurant von 40
gästen 23 mit corona infiziert frankfurt
am main optischen gemeinde 180 menschen
besuchen einen gottesdienst 112 steckten
sich an
es gilt währenddessen keine mundschutz
pflicht ausbrüche in den letzten tagen
zeigen auch dass es jedes jeden tag
wieder losgehen kann und wir immer
schnell und gut reagieren müssen dass es
uns bisher sehr gut gelungen im
restaurant in leer haben namenslisten
geholfen die infektionskette
nachzuverfolgen
noch besser wäre aber prävention also
abstand und hygiene regelungen
einzuhalten
ja also ganz grosses fragezeichen was
die lockerungen angeht und die die
auswirken die das haben kann
der stürmer aus rein biologischer sicht
sind das herz ausbrüche die wir gerade
gesehen haben die wir noch verkraften
können eben weil man genau weiß wer sich
infiziert hat und die kann man in
quarantäne stecken das ist die so
genannte kontakt verfolgung oder ist das
jetzt schon der beginn der zweiten welle
also genau kann man das glaube ich nicht
sagen
es sieht so aus als ob wir diese
ausbrüche unter kontrolle haben ich
glaube dass es elementar wichtig dass
das auch so bleibt
weil ich gehe davon aus dass das nicht
die letzten ausbrüche dieser form
gewesen sind sondern dass wir das auch
immer wieder jetzt sehen werden und so
zu befürchten ist dass es mehr wird und
das dann vielleicht noch mal einer
dieser ausbrüche eben nicht mehr zu 100
prozent eingefangen werden kann
und wenn wird uns das nicht mehr gelingt
dann werden wir die zweite welle
bekommen
hier gibt es jetzt auch dazu sehr
unterschiedliche meinungen also die
einen facebook auf facebook schreibt ali
coach die zweite welle wird viel
schlimmer kommen leider gottes und dann
ist da steht marvin tirol auch auf
facebook ich warte immer noch auf die
erste welle
also auch da gibt es ja sehr
unterschiedliche wahrnehmungen
vor allem aber gibt es hier von andrea
schmidt fand ich auch ganz interessant
die einschätzung nach dem viele aus
lockerungen beschlossen und gelebt
werden spricht frau merkel immer noch
vom anfang einer pandemie und hält
spuren ihrer meinung fest wie stehen sie
denn zu dieser aussage
ja das sind wir ja letztendlich auch
sind zwar in einer anderen phase der
pandemie aber immer noch am anfang weil
und darf nicht vergessen wie lange wir
über über saas kopf zwei überhaupt reden
wir sind jetzt im mai wir haben mitte
dezember die ersten fälle in haan gehabt
und dementsprechend sind wir noch nicht
über den berg wir befinden uns in einer
phase die scheinbar kontrolliert ist
wobei ich da auch schon das wort
scheinbar gerne unterstreichen würde
wir haben pro tag immer noch 4 500
neuinfektionen und wie man eben anhand
dieser ausbrüche dieser lokalen
ausbrüche sieht ist das virus nicht
verschwunden und es ist noch genauso
gefährlich und infektiös wie es am
anfang gewesen ist und nur weil wir
jetzt durch die lockerung ein relativ
entspannte situation in deutschland
haben heißt es nicht dass wir jetzt in
irgendeiner form uns auf dem weg der der
absoluten entspannung befinden
hier gibt es auch tatsächlich stimmen
die immer noch dass sich fragen was das
ganze eigentlich soll michael schulz
schreibt ihr auf facebook was es
eigentlich bei dieser sogenannten
pandemie passiert es gab tote ja es
bedauerlich aber nicht wirklich
erheblich selbst weltweit gesehen ist
sterben weit mehr täglich nur an hunger
die zahl kann ich das nicht überprüfen
und keiner interesse 1 interessiert ist
wenn ich jetzt eine zahl höre wie 4 bis
infizierte in deutschland pro tag denke
ich jetzt auch ja bei so einer anderen
infektionswelle grippe oder was es da
gibt es ja auch eine normale zahl
rechtfertigt dass die lockerungen noch
beziehungsweise andere machen ein großes
fragezeichen hinter ob es überhaupt was
passiert ist ja man muss sich natürlich
fragen weil es die hände und wer ist das
warum haben wir denn so wenig fälle
warum sehen wir in deutschland so wenig
tote
ja weil wir eben so rigoros am anfang zu
gemacht haben schauen sie nach brasilien
schauen sie in die usa das sind zb zwei
beispiele jetzt aktuell wo einfach von
seiten der politik am anfang versucht
wurde auch immer noch versucht wird das
virus klein zu reden und sie sehen was
für eine dynamik sich dort entwickelt
wie die menschen sterben und einfach ein
paar wochen zurück denken was in italien
passiert ist auch dort war die
anfängliche die die virus verbreitung
nicht unter kontrolle und wir haben
menschen reihenweise sterben sehen und
zwar deutlich mehr als wer im rahmen
einer normalen wer den anderen jahren
gesehen haben also die über
sterblichkeit in vielen ländern der welt
ist ist deutlich höher
jetzt aktuell als normal für wie
realistisch schätzen sie das ein dass
wir tatsächlich doch noch mal in so eine
situation kommen die nicht mehr
kontrollierbar ist ich meine wir haben
ja jetzt doch die erste welle gut
geritten und überstanden wir haben
intensiv werden ordentlich aufgestockt
die menschen wissen wie sie sich
einigermaßen verhalten soll zumindest
die meisten
das heißt im grunde können wir doch
gelassen in die zukunft gucken oder
nicht sie haben eben einen wichtigen
punkt angesprochen das verhalten der
menschen ist jetzt entscheidend von uns
allen
wir haben in gerade in den zeiten wo es
besonders hart war mit den restriktiven
maßnahmen haben wir gelernt wie man sich
optimal verhält wir haben gelernt dass
am besten man versucht so viel wie
möglich an aktivitäten zu vermeiden
wir haben abstand gelernt
hygienemaßnahmen gelernt wenn wir dieses
wissen und dieses was wir erlernt haben
jetzt auch in der zukunft weiter
behalten
dann kann man es gut möglich sein dass
wir eben keine zweite welle in der form
bekommen sondern dass wir es bei
einzelfällen wie jetzt eben frankfurt
oder
haben dass es dabei bleibt aber das
liegt an uns allen wie wir uns jetzt im
alltag verhalten und wie wir mit den
mehr und mehr dazu kommen freiheiten
umgehen wenn wir damit anfangen zu
leichtsinnig umzugehen miteinander und
die bekannten maßnahmen jetzt außer acht
lassen und ignorieren
dann werden wir in eine zweite welle
reinrutschen hier gibt's einen kommentar
auf youtube von maria die schreibt ich
bin alt und kann selbst auf mich
aufpassen corona zu bekommen ist eher
schwerer als ein sechser im lotto
was sagen sie denn dazu nein ist es
nicht
wie gesagt das sehen wir jetzt in dieser
praktischsten gemeinde und dann sehen
wir auch wie schnell und wie viele
menschen letztendlich infiziert worden
sind und ich selber habe mir das virus
auch eingefangen im skiurlaub
auch wir sind nicht bewusst irgendwelche
risiken eingegangen wir waren weder
apres ski feiern noch sonst irgendwas es
ist kein virus wo ich mich extrem
anstrengen muss um es zu bekommen
definitiv nicht das noch mal vielleicht
jetzt zum abschluss wissen wie ist das
in dieser kiste gemeinde zu erklären
also es gibt ja durchaus fälle wo sich
menschen da ihrem ehepartner nicht
angesteckt haben wo ganze familie nicht
nicht infiziert waren obwohl einer das
virus hatte und jetzt gibt es einen
einzigen gottesdienst wo die menschen
nur wenige stunden zusammen sind gut auf
engem raum sie haben keine masken
getragen sie haben gesungen das ist
vielleicht alles schwierig gewesen und
trotzdem ist fast die komplette gemeinde
infiziert wie kann so etwas passieren
ja da ist natürlich immer verschiedene
faktoren wie so eine infektion
stattfinden kann sie müssen einen
infizierten haben der ordentlich virus
produziert im rachen der mustern das
virus entsprechend ausscheiden und es
muss natürlich in einer umgebung sein wo
sich eben diese tröpfchen oder das aero
sowohl je nachdem was es gewesen ist
sehr sehr gut verbreitet hat und uns
sehr viele menschen im prinzip damit in
verbindung gekommen sind das sind so die
grundvoraussetzung dass sowas bekommt
als sie brauchen eine person die das
virus extrem gut verbreitet und dann
wie gesagt in dieser baptistengemeinde
war ja ein begrenzter raum
sie haben es richtig gesagt die masken
wurden nicht getragen das war jetzt kein
verstoß gegen die vorschriften im
nachgang wer ist sicherlich besser
gewesen diese getragen zu haben und
durch das ding ist eben entsprechend
auch eine doch deutlich höhere
produktion an infektiösen partikeln als
bei einem normalen sprechen zum beispiel
und das ist dann die sache mit dem aero
suhl wo wir gerade gelernt haben dass
das wahrscheinlich das größere problem
sein kann
das kommt jetzt noch dazu dass wir jetzt
auch wieder einen neuen erkenntnisstand
errungen haben auch da lernt jetzt auch
die der normale bürger wie wissenschaft
funktioniert wie wir lernen ja auch mit
dem virus
es ist ja nicht so dass wir von anfang
an alles wissen und alles wissen können
weil auch wir dieses virus erst seit ein
paar monaten kennen und die erosion
übertragung ist etwas was auch jetzt
relativ neu sich herauskristallisiert
dass es wohl doch eine signifikante
rolle spielt was vorher an den daten die
wir hatten nicht sichtbar gewesen ist
und durch viele fall berichtet kommt es
jetzt heraus dass es eigentlich nur mit
e rosol übertragung erkläre es wie sich
in bestimmten umgebungen menschen
angesteckt haben können also wir sind
dabei die wissenschaft lernt das ist
auch für uns als öffentlichkeit eine
steile lernkurve
ich danke ihnen für das gespräch heute
abend herrscht immer mal wieder ich
bedanke mich nicht bei euch für eure
kommentare und fragen und würde sagen
wir werden nur das thema auf jeden fall
noch eine ganze weile mit uns
herumschleppen aber für heute machen wir
erstmal ein deckel drauf in diesem sinne
macht's gut
und tschüss
[Musik]
und wenn euch das team gefallen hat dann
guck doch mal hier rein da haben wir
über die frage gesprochen warum so viele
menschen einer corona verschwörung
glauben oder hier mit harald lesch über
die welt nach kroner und natürlich guckt
mal eben unsere playlist und tasten und
ein abo da